[Music]
so all of these are from dead people
and they're just everywhere
thailand has some of the most dangerous
roads in the world
every year tens of thousands of people
die on them
yes so far coronavirus has killed
[Music]
so how is it that thailand can seemingly
control a pandemic
but can't cut deaths on the road
[Music]
for thailand's volunteer paramedics
there is no rest
minutes into the shift the first call
out
where are we going now we have uh the
car accident
someone's got an injury but you know how
severe yeah
a minimum 20 000 people die on these
roads
every year making them the ninth most
dangerous in the world
do you think it's going to be bad
a motorbike carrying two men has crashed
one's injured his leg the other may be
more serious
he wasn't wearing a helmet so what's
happening here is they're quickly
assessing the scene and then deciding
whether they need to call in the next
level of support here so how bad are the
injuries do these people
need to go to hospital do they need more
experienced paramedics on the scene
well it's less than five minutes since
we got back to the last call and they're
already out on the road again and these
guys have one focus
to get there first and to get there fast
what happened here this car turned live
and motorcycle is crashed and taken
under the
car this man's expected to
recover but on average 62 people
die on the roads here every day
despite various government pledges
deaths on thailand's roads have hovered
around
20 000 every year for the last decade
and next year
they're promising to try and cut that by
around 45
but just a day on ship with these guys
and that seems utterly unattainable
and the calls keep on coming more
drivers without helmets
people speeding suspected
drunks and then this
a car has driven into the canal totally
submerged
it looks
but the shivering driver has amazingly
escaped
he tells me he managed to open the door
before the car
sunk
night after night the cycle continues
the country which has managed to keep
covid 19 deaths to around
60 has lost more than 8 000
this year to crashes how is it that
thailand
can keep covert deaths low but it can't
cut dramatically the number of people
being killed on its roads
right people don't expect the rule
they're not frightened of roads but
they're frightened of covert
thailand's road deaths have become an
[Music]
obsession
there's helmets everywhere all along the
walls here his piles of
salvaged helmets are an ever-growing
memorial to the dead and injured
a warning to the living and what's this
doll over here
so all of these are from dead people
more than 700
battered helmets taken from accident
sites
a reminder to drivers to be safe
and they're just everywhere visors
helmets hubcaps
all along the wall here you know like
deep in
the undergrowth these are really strange
you can see that the
plant has actually started growing into
the helmets here it's almost like
they're part of his house inside he
shows us three of the newest
all of the owners are dead
he tells us locals who borrow the
helmets quickly return them saying
they're haunted
but for some pong it's important to keep
the memories
from
it's actually really disturbing he's
just been showing us those three helmets
but the reality is if you drive a
motorbike here you're more likely to be
involved in a fatal crash
around three quarters of all killer
crashes here
are people on motorbikes and still half
the drivers
only wear helmets and only 20 percent of
the passengers
it's just crazy
his task is endless the bodies keep on
mounting up
on thailand's roads
you know all the time on the news we
talk about huge numbers of people who
die on the roads and sometimes when you
say these massive figures 10 000
20 000 kind of doesn't mean anything in
real life and then
you see these helmets and suddenly it
does
this is the moment saranya's life
changed forever
her five-year-old daughter cartoon and
her husband were outside the family's
shop
when a speeding driver plowed into them
[Music]
survived but suffered severe injuries
and brain damage
she's paralyzed and blind she cannot
speak
she cannot feed herself she can only
move her eyes
the driver responsible for paralyzing a
child and killing her dad got a year's
jail sentence
and couldn't pay the compensation needed
to cover the hospital bills
[Music]
while police carry out random spot
checks for unsafe and drunk drivers
campaigners agree penalties are too low
[Music]
this woman is more than two times over
the legal limit
that could mean a fine of up to 500
pounds
in some cases jail but safety groups
claim
too often people with money and power
can buy their way out of trouble
something the authorities deny do people
try and pay you
and say don't find me here's the money
yeah maybe
some people try to pay us but we didn't
accept
so when they try what happens
so we explained the raw that you have to
go to the police station
and the fourth session will send you to
the card every morning in uh tomorrow
morning
so you have to pay the five at the car
the government says it's cracking down
on bribes that sentences are tough
and it's working on a new road safety
plan but ultimately
all this will fail unless drivers change
their habits
still the country that's currently got
coveted 19
under control is confident it can do the
same
with road deaths
[Music]
foreign
but tens of thousands more ties will die
in crashes while they wait for change
this year's death tolls are down
slightly
but unbelievably it's kovid 19 that's
inadvertently saved hundreds of lives on
thailand's roads
lockdown kept people at home and forced
a temporary
shift in behavior but keeping road
deaths low long term
will take more than a pandemic that
requires
a total research
you